I didn't get a chance to tell you this
uh Steve because I guess you have caller
ID
um but
Marty took the call yeah I did and when
you guys co-hosted SNL
I watched that I mean recently yeah oh
that's the only time we've co-hosted
yeah that's right of all the time or was
it 40 years ago
um it was uh last season and you guys
did this monologue and it was over and
I've worked there I've seen thousands of
SNL monologues over the years I cut my
teeth on that show as a young kid
watching TV and I said that is the best
Saturday Night Live monologue I've ever
seen it was perfect so you didn't like
my other monologues I did no yeah
yeah well whenever you would come out to
do a monologue on SNL
um you know everyone knew that was the
time to go get a drink yeah well here's
what use the bathroom no here's but it
was perfect it was absolute perfection
okay
uh so that model we you know we worked
on with the writers we got some things
but we we decided we're going to do a
bit from our show so that will know we
can trust it yeah so afterwards it went
well and the ratings were Sky High was
the highest rated show of the year as
far as I know and uh I said to Marty
um Marty you know the monologue went
great and uh the ratings were high so
there's a chance we'll be asked back to
host at some other time and I said and
before you say yes just remember we
worked on that monologue for three years
you guys had this
I know it's part of your show but
God it's a good idea the I care about
Steve and I care about Marty and it's so
much so that I've prepared the eulogy
already you know that I'm going to give
for you and you each have them on you
and you
damn it it's funny well it's one of the
funniest things it's such a great and
the minute I hear that the minute I
heard the idea I was saying oh oh this
is a Kill Zone well the funniest line to
me is is Steve's opening line when it
goes no no no no this time for me to
talk remember narcissism is just within
your thing no
no pre-story to that and then you can
say that well first of all I was going
to do your line so you might as well
keep talking no no you do the line I'm
just saying that
I had this idea that we would do this
eulogy but I couldn't get I said I just
don't know how it starts I don't know
you know there'll be some jokes or
something and then actually a writer
send in and and this line so it would be
me so you be me speaking so the lights
come down and it says remembering Marty
and Steve's opening line is
Gene not much of a turnout
but it enabled the whole piece because
we could get into it with the first
laugh right yeah right right it is uh
it's funny too because
I love it occasionally you get someone
who thinks why are they being mean to
each other yeah and and that always
drives me crazy the funniest thing to me
is when you know we're doing our thing
and he'll say something I'll say
something and you'll hear someone in the
audience go whoa
I remember one time being on Conan show
and you know I insulted them a great
deal and then I went to the next I was
on I went to YouTube to see what jokes
I'd done and I read the comments below
and people would say you know he
shouldn't talk Conan that way if Conan
wanted to he could take him apart
that's a fun person to have dinner with
I know why are you making jokes
[Laughter]
when I was first doing the Late Night
show we did a piece where you know the
most beloved one of the most beloved
people at the time was Mary Lou Retton
the gymnast and she's you know small and
cute and she won all these gold medals
and everyone loves her and we did a
pre-tape bit
where I think Andy says I'm saying I
think I'm getting the hang of this late
night the hosting thing and goes Andy
goes like you know you could yeah but
the other night I thought you you were a
little off and I said I don't know what
you're talking about he we cut to a
pre-tape of me just losing it on Mary
Lou Retton and I'm screaming at her
fully committed and we showed that
audience laughs
I think the next day or the day after
that I go on Stern
Howard Stern he takes calls and someone
calls in
I saw the other night
and you your behavior towards Mary Lou
Retton was atrocious I don't think
you're funny that was awful the way you
spoke to her that's I mean I can't
believe you didn't recognize my voice
reminds me of a
reminds me of a story I don't know if
these are like older elderly stories but
Mike Nichols you know was married to uh
is was married to Diane Sawyer and he
was you know he was a hilariously funny
guy and he would he would say things
like um uh that invite him to a party he
said well I'll have to run by the ball
and chain so he would call Diana's ball
and chain as a joke so then and I think
it was uh Vogue yeah they said evidently
Mike Nichols refers to his wife as the
ball and chain yeah you know it's a
negative thing so he wrote them a letter
which I think they published but said I
realize that humor to your editors is
like a cross to a vampire
hahaha